this is a production of cornell
university
yeah welcome back everybody this is the
the fourth week of our cornell turf show
this year seventh episode uh we're
excited to have dr olga kostrometska
from umass amherst uh olga is a
turfgrass entomologist
we're going to pick her brain today
about maybe some annual bluegrass weeble
stuff where they're at how they
overwintered possibly chinch bug things
and frank i'm sure you'll have some
questions there
um but as always we'll start off with
with frank rossi and
a little bit of a weather recap and and
some recent events we uh we've been
working on at the cornell turf team here
thanks carl you can hear me okay and see
the slides
yep okay good
uh this you know in the background again
big shout out to the met and the long
island superintendents and we were with
the upstate superintendents the gcsa and
y
uh yesterday at saratoga national where
uh joe wins the contest for the biggest
tractor sprayer uh i think i've seen yet
in a turf operation that that used to
belong to uh brookfield country club
with that big monster that adam outhou
had out there but this is this is the
new winner it was a a great day
yesterday carl and before uh we get
going and i pass it off to you uh just a
couple of funny tweets uh with masters
coming up and people out uh swinging the
golf club love these the yardage markers
that they put out there uh on the par
fives but of course carl this wouldn't
apply to you at all
uh there's no such thing as no chance
for you and with that let me introduce
you and have you go through the tip of
the week
yeah so so frank we've been running
through these every week this is part of
our our project with the p2i center
um looking at golf course bmps and
trying to highlight these every week and
we've got a couple on this infographic
poster that we've been focused on the
last couple years
and they have both have to do with
longer vegetation on the golf course and
this can help you with water quality
helping filter some of those pollutants
sediments nutrients as it's getting
closer to a water body
it can also reduce our mowing and reduce
our carbon footprint
so there's a couple statistics on this
that we have
based on how wide that buffer we call
these a vegetative buffer when they're
around a water body based on how wide
that is that can really decrease the
sediment in this case 40 to 90 percent
the wider the better so if you have a
20-foot buffer that's better than a
10-foot buffer
yesterday frank we actually discussed
this with joe lucas at his field day he
has water bodies that that meander
through the golf course and he's
actually tested those for water quality
and as the water flow through flows
through his golf course it gets cleaner
it has less sediment it has less
nutrient
concentrations and that's because he has
these sort of vegetative buffers
so wider is better and variety is better
so diversity in the vegetation
also helps with the water quality
component and then we have the mowing
component right so over here on the
right is a picture of locust hill
country club when rick slattery was
introducing some of these long grass we
can call them native areas there's a
bunch of different terminology for them
but at its very core you just mow it
less instead of mowing that once per
week as rough
you mow it maybe one to two times a year
and some of our data but based on on how
often you mow it what mower you mow with
you can save 100 to 400 pounds of co2
emissions per year per acre from from
these uh transitioning these areas from
rough to long grass and and we might
have a conversation today about how long
grass affects uh turf grass pests but
but this is a really great way to start
thinking about these as a benefit to the
environment reducing uh carbon emissions
and improving water quality
and and carl just uh call you out here a
little bit uh as we've developed the par
birdie eagle approach right i wonder if
you couldn't talk about why these long
grass areas
are considered an eagle it seems like
stopping mowing uh is is not so hard and
the buffer zones you got as a birdie uh
you know what's so hard about uh not
cutting the grass
yeah and the the variable here that
makes it hard frank is the golfers right
and the golfers and we're going to see
this at augusta national this week a lot
of closely known areas right down to
water hazards
uh and at high-end golf courses where
you want that sort of
the drama of a ball rolling rolling
rolling down into the water we like
seeing that on tv golfers would like to
have that at their golf course they're
not they're not so happy when it's going
in the water
um and and when they get their ball into
long grass okay they get frustrated i
can't find my golf ball i have to drop
it i have to lose the golf ball
so that's the big that's the big
hindrance right the superintendents
would love to do this but there's an
aesthetic component there's a
playability component that needs to be
considered and we've used some data
we'll talk about that maybe in a later
turf show with with our usga friends and
how you can use data to justify these
areas
but that's really what makes these
birdies and eagles it's not the actual
implementation it's golf golf is a
recreational component and our golfers
moving around the golf course is what
prevents us from from doing more of this
perfect carl excellent thank you and
we'll look forward to that as as we
maybe talk more about the deacon thing
but since you brought up data
and yesterday at the saratoga conference
uh the walk and talk we had yesterday
with about 35 40 folks um
kevin doyle our gcsaa rep was there and
made a shout out to provide a response
to the survey that's out they're doing
the third phase of the nutrient
management survey nutrient pest
management survey so this is where we
can say that bmps are working right by
our more responsible use and in many
cases lower use of these inputs right
one would think that a lot of our bmps
are around using less you can't know
you're getting better if you don't
measure things so these are our
contributions uh to helping us benchmark
an entire industry about the way we
should be using nutrients uh so big
shout out thanks to kevin for coming
yesterday and everybody that supported
us okay so let's get to the nitty-gritty
and and to our our our wonderful guests
that we'll get to chat about uh things
crawling around before we get there
we'll start with the rainfall looks like
last week
had a fair amount of rainfall uh in the
two to three inch range through much of
the hudson valley orange county uh
northern jersey uh maybe not as much out
on long island but certainly through the
valleys the pioneer valley to hudson
valley up through there you're getting a
fair amount of rainfall and it looks
like the hudson valley the capital
district the adirondacks all the way
down to new york city is in for about a
one to two inch rain period uh into new
england uh through what through monday
looks like it's going to be wet through
monday rt guy tunnel to artiguytano
from the climate center told us this
morning
it looks like we're going to be ridgy he
says which means we're on the ridge side
of the um
of the jet stream which means warm and
wet uh weather is underway are on its
way uh last week again we were a little
bit on the cooler side and we said this
right uh some of the northern areas are
on the warmer side but overall
normal or right around normal and as we
said last week not a big degree day
accumulation so if you look at the uh
how we've accumulated since the middle
of march you know we're right around
normal somewhere between 20 degrees 20
degree days below and 20 degree days
above normal so that could be you know
literally a day or two but the forecast
uh is not very good moving forward again
single digit to low teens of degree day
accumulation so we're again looking at
least in the near term at least until
the middle of next week
a little cooler but it appears that a
warm-up is on the way so the forecast is
calling for a warm-up but looking at the
soil temperature right now you can see
just a few weeks ago we were in the low
50s and we're creeping to get into the
low 50s even in the southern most
regions of new jersey so we're now we're
back down into the 40s as a soil
temperature at least as of yesterday
for those of you fussing around with
annual bluegrass still
and have seed head suppression or those
of you who have stockpiled the embark uh
much of the southern northeastern region
uh through the metropolitan new york
area is is in the window or past the
window of embark a lot of our a lot of
my friends that have some embark still
check on this particular model and like
it
this was actually the embark model we
verified here in new york a number of
years ago so we feel really confident
about that and the proxy model now is
indicating uh almost everybody is in the
ideal and early marginal stage uh except
for the most northern region so again
things are on pause but if you're doing
seed head suppression there's still
opportunities for this now
obviously you can't travel around the
northeast and being in the capital
district it wasn't hard to find some
areas that still had some damage
this came off of a particular golf
course that had some ball mark uh annual
bluegrass damage you can see moving in
in these areas and on the left you see
it's starting to recover when you look
on the right you can really see let me
get my pen here you can really see for
of course for the podcast you have no
idea what i'm talking about but on the
on the video you can see that these
plants are all coming out of
dead uh material there so you want to be
really careful when you start to see the
existing plants that might have looked
dead a few days ago or weeks ago
are starting to surge now
the rainfall will be welcome sometimes
these plants come up and don't have root
systems so keep an eye on them so that
while you're getting leaf growth you
make sure you're getting those root
systems because if you get dry
right if you get dry and the damage to
these plants is to the root cells like
we've talked about you're going to have
a tough time uh generating new plant
materials so moisture very very
important when you see recovery looking
like this out of existing plants versus
maybe new seedlings that are coming from
seed now here's a good example of some
impacts that covers can have so here you
have the back of this particular green
greening up
the front
not as green and again not that one is
better than the other but if you're
encouraging recovery you can see the
impact that a permeable cover a
permeable cover
on the right has now
it's so great this show right people uh
i have colleagues at green jacket is the
cover company in minnesota
gary sullivan uh sent us some data
that's been collected from the
university of massachusetts from dr dr
decosta's work michelle decosta's work
um and this is the difference between
certain uh permeable and imper certain
impermeable covers that actually can
warm up and one of the things that the
green jacket
person was saying was that their
impermeable cover
maintains the temperature more
moderately through
uh the green up phase so you're looking
here in march
right every two hours for nine days and
this is just looking at two days and you
can see the fluctuations under some
types of covers versus others
and that a permeable cover that's
maintaining that uh dormancy underneath
there right
gives you this advantage of not having
to play the game of on and off but if
you're looking for recovery at this
stage of the game obviously the ability
to drive up that temperature uh is going
to be going to be quite a bit more
useful now just say you know all the
cool things on twitter come from
everybody doing a little bit of science
on their own so it's a golf course
superintendent i think down in north
carolina or virginia or something has
taken a picture of this fairway over a
period of time look at the difference
between 2013
and 15 and here's the difference between
2020 and 2022
right just so that you know i would put
these pictures up in the locker rooms if
i had a club to say hey in case you
forgot you know this is the variability
that we're getting uh under spring
conditions so it's i i think a really
good way to tell the story now listen as
we get to our conversation for today it
starts with what a lot of people are
doing nowadays looking at the greencast
website looking for what the scouting is
saying and right now when i go in and
log in at my
zip code it's it's telling me to wait
for an application um i've been looking
at some
recent golf course management article
that continues to highlight some
different phenological indicators here's
a particular hydrangea
olga that now we think might have some
value but the conversation for this
morning as we get to looking at you in a
second is about what's going to be
happening soon you know what we've
learned uh about the adults emerging
when they're gonna feed when they're
gonna copulate on the left and when
they're in this particular case a really
cool picture
where they put their eggs inside the
sheath of the annual bluegrass plant now
this is again some work i talked about
with ben last year that you probably
have some familiarity with about the
average eggs you know how long they
carry them when they're laying them uh
and how they're timed up with this right
because this is all about that spring
emergence time but at the same time olga
what i know you have a front row seat at
is okay you've got a lot of people out
there who the who the adult decides you
know might not work as well and they're
having to
uh go to the larvae side and uh maybe
that is a better strategy as as well and
so as i you know look at you and we
start to chat about this
let's start with but you know we're
going to go through this whole thing i
just did in four slides let's start with
where we are now in
populations and uh where we think some
timings will be in the near term week or
so so where are we out and what the
emergence data is starting to say
so
yes we start already sampling from march
18 that's our first sample
and we start seeing them from march 18
and what we do yeah i described last
year too what we tried to do second year
we tried to progress now sampling from
the overwintering side and the fairways
so that's how we do it if i got any
vehicles if you collect i try to dissect
see where are they in the development i
continue to second year and what i can
say in uh we saw vivos already in
march mostly on the refs we didn't see
them on the fairway so this year as you
described with the weather pattern i
would call very usual normal year and
that's what how we started like with
evils and everything they start slowly
progressing from their winter insides
and we haven't seen and by the end of
the march we haven't seen them on the
fairway yet
however now when we
start sampling last week and this week
we start seeing them on fairways already
and according to what i teach at least i
see that the
persidia should be in a full bloom when
we start seeing the first weevils
i i haven't seen this this year but for
city anywhere close similar to the last
year and so so this one we kind of need
to a little bit review because i i see
the weevils they still not in the full
activity you still see a lot of the
rough still they still coming but the
pioneers already there and when i
dissected pioneers females they have
eggs already formed in there
uh the yes they have eggs but the
question like you said probably will
take some time to mate and lay them but
they are fully uh formed okay so listen
all right so here's where i want okay
what i've learned from listening to all
you smart people
about annual bluegrass weevil is that um
this is a time when um
i've got a single stage
uh that shows their uh you know that are
out and about yes that i can target and
what i've been able to follow and let's
just stay on where normal adult decides
will work let's stay off the resistance
thing let's just say where you've got
adulticides that will work
the
the what i've heard you guys continue to
stress is
wait till the peak yes don't go early
don't make four apps before the p so you
know this is what i think a lot of
people ban you know struggle with it is
it too early do i want to miss it so can
you talk a little bit about a little bit
of patience and waiting for the peak and
some signals obviously not for cynthia
but some signals that were getting
closer to the peak yes the interesting
thing before cdm well i'm glad you
mentioned that that uh the peak actually
pretty precise it's the start of the
activity they cut
maybe not as good but they have green
have gold and it's pretty golden
standard still you know like that's what
i don't know this year but definitely
been years before and about what
in this areas we talked about hundred
growing degrees maybe close to 100 and
that's where the peak why do you wait
for the peak because
look at the weather in the spring yeah
we have some with full eggs they still
need to have some time to make and be
ready to lay their eggs
but it's not all of that it's just few
it's pioneers so you don't want to put
all your chemicals just to target you
it's biological systems never will be
100 percent coming all on the fairway
lax all at once so that's why we're
looking um
scientifically where most of them will
be there and so far it's been pretty
precisely predicted by the degree based
model and the for citable blooming uh
like i said before maybe it's not as
precise with the start of the activity
but it's definitely precise with the
when you try to do okay so then so then
the next question is i know the optimum
time do i literally have to blanket the
place or can i just spray fairways if i
think i have him in my rough but it's
not causing damage can i be a little bit
more particular with where i treat so as
to not have to treat 80 acres versus
maybe 20. yeah absolutely i always like
stress what it should be fairway
you know like that's like there's two
schools of use you can do perimeter
people do but it doesn't mean what you
spray everything it's perimeter certain
you know like you don't spray in the
middle of fairway and another school of
thoughts you have to spray
fairway only i'm more inclined to
suggest fairway only don't touch the
rafts my
and some people really think what the
perimeter works i will not argue against
that right now i'm just saying why i do
believe the fairway is better to treat
first of all because that's their target
destination
if they're going through the rafts it's
temporarily for them they will be ending
up on the fairway right so it's better
to protect them the fairways we don't
want to protect the rafts because there
will not lay eggs there and secondly
sometimes that's what i notice couple
years then they could go in the middle
and if you don't spray the middle you
can end up not as great obviously not
the same damage as edges but they still
possible what you have if you have four
in the middle you might have some damage
which you want to avoid so that's why i
wouldn't suggest
that's that's what i'm definitely for
spraying the fairways
is there any um okay that's perfect this
exactly the kind of answer we want
really site-specific stuff
but before i i want to sort of take it
to the putting surfaces now um we got a
lot of damaged annual bluegrass on the
putting surfaces um i don't know how
palatable or unpalatable or if they even
care uh they obviously have to have
sheets to lay in live sheets to lay down
i think yeah they like it yeah so i
wouldn't i wouldn't necessarily think
they'd care but collars surrounds do i
have to spray my putting surfaces or can
i loop my putting surfaces
that's a good uh that's a good question
i
i don't know i
in the pot and it's when for me has less
reasons that's not the only really you
do need to get the colors for sure
because potting usually is not as big as
fairway and just protect it i think it's
not that much more chemical and they
will definitely move much faster
on the greens because it's a smoother
surface and they much faster there so if
they on the greens they will just go all
over so okay that's like maybe it's a
new fear would you get them out but i
heard this last year some damage in the
green so i wouldn't really yeah we don't
want you to take any down okay i did i
did heard about the green damage last
year okay so here's what again you know
you as an agronomist i listened to this
enough and so i you know formulated in
my head
and now i have this sense that
try as i might
i'm going to miss adults either i have
pyrethroid resistance i'm not addressing
or i'm missing the peak and then i get
into that asynchronicity
um so let's talk uh about
the importance of you know getting a
peak but also maybe if you've had a
history
starting to already think about a
larvicide
so i don't know maybe i don't want to go
there first what do i do if i got
pyrethroid resistance in new york
without chlorpyrifos
one more time i know we talked about
this last year i want to hear from you
again what do i do without chlorpyrifos
on my
highly resistant
pyrethroid population so
the rule of thumb there is no adult
aside
for resistance even if you have
immediate or moderate if you have ever
pared through its failure
just avoid because we don't have uh for
pure force even for resistance would be
not effective anyways so i would avoid
adult decides for sure because you will
push the population you will definitely
not get as much control out of that this
waste of time and it's making even worse
situations so i would definitely avoid
it all sides here's other several
options there uh we kind of try to throw
here like a little bit early large
science as one options and for now what
we have the diamines
and if you have highly resistance avoid
uh
chlorantraniliprol
that's a celloprint right that's a cell
yeah it's where it's effective and i
hear that people say it's not a good
vivo product i wouldn't say it's
in general it's a good product but if
you have at least slightest resistance
the efficacy of this product it's
definitely decreases so if you want you
want to go for
maybe a scientia nello prone and i think
the new one was registered with the
trend neutral they have some dynamites
which could work so and then probably
you can apply it's uh you see the peak
of activity of adults you decide not to
go any to do anything about that so wait
about two weeks and that's you can
basically start looking into applying
this early larva sides and then all
right yes and then if you go the late
alert with science it's not enjoyable
normal our state is about there will be
2.53 in stars then you have entire shed
of toolshed of everything what you can
apply so it's much easier there okay so
let me go through this again because
this is your recent paper this is the
recent paper in golf course management's
that's addressing the the intersection
of the pyrethroid resistant populations
and the decision to go to adulticides
and the impact that that resistance
has on the larvacides working
that's what we're talking okay so you're
saying uh and i gotta forgive me i'm not
as good with some of the insecticides uh
acelloprine does not work as well as a
larvicide when you've got pyrethroid
resistance
in the existing in the population okay
that's the first thing that's important
there are others you said cyan are
trying to pill and trying to pill yeah
those are what ference is that parents
parents and like what the trina the new
one i i'm i haven't done too much
research with katrina and resistance so
i wouldn't say it for sure so but
definitely we learned that the science
channel pro it does it's not the fact
that the the fair and still will be
effective for for larva and another one
and another one later which we have
found which didn't have pyrethroid
resistance didn't have any effect on its
spinoza and spinozad
right yeah okay so let me go through
this again because i'm hearing you say
you have a lot of pyrethroid resistance
you can't even
adult the sides forget it
you're not going to be effective
you better and you have to be more
thoughtful about your larvicides
and
early larvacide
uh activity is very impacted by
resistance but as you wait
i'm hearing you say
you have more possibilities because that
resistance doesn't seem to be
impacting them as much the later in the
instar
of the larvae this is a very different
conversation than i think i've ever had
with an abw person
focusing on discrete larvicide timings
uh yes
right
yeah i think it's like start coming from
like again it's we did it in new jersey
and when i was a postdoc and it's kind
of uh
the
early larva sides we want to target
first instar while they still in in the
stems and it's tricky obviously because
the timing but approximately if you know
your adult aside timing and speak of the
activity and you don't do it so wait
about two weeks i would say and that
will be a good timing so it's a little
bit early right for for this chemicals
but that's why we only applying systemic
and in this case diamine because nothing
else is really good for wheels and
after
afterwards if you this will be one when
the opportunity and the second window
opportunity when they start coming out
they're still not really big they just
start coming out from the stamps start
feeding on the crowns and then about the
same chemical still pretty good plus you
have spinozad which we can add and other
chemicals somewhat affected so if you
have really highly resistant population
basically it's between diamines and
spinozens and that's basically it but if
you have
less level of resistance still
susceptible then you have other things
like
carb which could be used um
maybe i don't remember too many ops for
that because if you try to stay away
from them anyways
yeah yeah for sure yeah but you have
some more things available yeah okay so
listen before we get out of here carl
we're gonna we're already at the hour so
i want i got one more for sure unless
there's any from the audience
how worried are you
okay
you're basically suggesting
that once you get resistance
you better be almost thinking about it
with a history of damage to potentially
two larvicide applications
one
two weeks after your peak adult timing
emergence and you think really
confidently that's half green half gold
about a hundred growing degree days
right yes among them right
and then how much longer after that
because this isn't easy to scout for it
it's different than the adults right
this is a little trickier to scout for
isn't it
yes the the larva sides basically
especially for the early larva side it's
tricky timing because you're relying on
your adult presence right and maybe the
growing degree days around 200 right but
for for the most part you you cannot you
will not see them even like i i usually
like you can use all the tools available
for you out there to which i sample
every day too and like but
but that's what approximately timing
because the first installation you will
not see them in the soil
even if you sample with the salt
extraction not likely you'll see them
because even for me i need some like i
have eye for them but for people who
don't they need magnification
and like now we even switched
like ben was like the pioneer in that
if we switch from the salt solution for
for the early larva sides we switched to
the releasing final extraction because
they come in and it's easy to see them
it's not as much
uh trash unfortunately i had not really
good uh
uh experience the text in the larger
larva like that so we have to go back to
the soul for the larger but okay yeah so
so yes it's basically relying on
approximately 200 of the growing degree
days two weeks from adult activity but
something like that
okay all right volga thank you so much
this is i we could chat about this for
another half an hour for sure because as
the resistance comes up and the
challenges come up and you know we still
have annual bluegrass and even if this
thing you know doesn't like annual
bluegrass it'll find something else to
feed on so appreciate you keeping up
this great work
i don't want to open surgical units at
golf courses to start dissecting annual
bluegrass feed exactly exactly yeah
yes i think it's a lot of tools for you
guys
available today to just see the timing
and suggestions what and when should be
applied so
good work keep up the great work carl
get us out of here
yeah thanks thanks to to dr castromeiska
for joining us today um thanks again as
always frank it's been the seventh
episode this year at the cornell turf
show tomorrow we're gonna have ben
palmer on to talk early season sports
field management so we'll have
another massachusetts
we're going total massachusetts this
we're spending a lot of time near boston
frank we're getting dangerously close to
uh all these red sox folks
thanks a
lot see you soon see you guys
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu